if you had to update us on how much
progress we've made senior advisor to
the president also the president's
son-in-law Jared Kushner okay I'm
listening to the president numbers today
and I'm proud of impressed toes where we
are this is something we now have more
iterations of testing approved how many
tests can we get done in May and June
and how does that help reopening the
country Thank You Sean well the
president I've just left him he's in the
Oval Office working late and he really
was quite pleased with the progress
we've made today to give America the
tools that we need to open up safely
testing is a major component of that
today we passed nine point three million
tests we get our best testing day yet we
had three hundred and ninety four
thousand seven hundred and eleven tests
compare that to sixty days ago basically
on March 11th we did three thousand
seven hundred and forty eight so that's
over a hundred times increase in testing
from where we were 60 days the ramp up
continues to be extraordinary and
President Trump continues to put the
full force of the federal government to
behind to do everything we need to get
all the resources we need to minimize
the the damage that's being caused right
now by the virus but also to get our
country open he used the defense
production act to create ventilators
last year we did 30,000 ventilators the
president so far is on track to do over
150,000 ventilators this year he's doing
swabs he's doing masks he's making all
kinds of things here in America which is
really great and that's giving us the
ability we need to make sure that we can
open the country up safely so we had on
March 2nd both the governor of New York
mayor and he'll go out on the town we're
fine we're New Yorkers president built
all the hospitals he manned them he
covered 19 converted him he provided
every ventilator mask respirator shield
gowns and gloves and then they sent the
people to old people homes and didn't
use 2,000 beds at the Javits Center and
nearly a thousand beds on the Comfort
why we only have a minute well this
isn't about pointing fingers Shawn look
this is an unprecedented challenge it
was an unprecedented challenge for the
president for the governors for the
mayors and we all came together we
worked very closely with New York we
sent them four thousand four hundred
ventilators we've sent them money we've
sent them resources we sent them people
we sent them masks
the goal here was just to make sure that
we can get all the resources we needed
to the frontline
make sure the people who were in danger
from the virus got what they needed and
thankfully in New York and throughout
the country anyone who needed a
ventilator got a ventilator and we've
been able to bring good results of the
country all right Jared thank you for
being with us